can you tell me about this is this the
new Aladdin line yeah no this you know
this is little little late-night Genie
vibes I'm just giving him a little
late-night Genie vibes you know I was
just feeling sexy about myself am i
doing too much be honest because because
I need it because I trust George I'm
going to tell you the truth but take a
good look look I'm gonna look we'll take
a picture of it and we'll bring it back
to you in like a year or two no I like
but you can do this you can do have some
turtle swag you know what cuz it's not
about the clothes about the inside like
you got to exude your clothes hi yike
you can put the clothes on and you got
to exude um hi oh one summons me I stand
by my loyalty two wishes three I'm
kidding
Russians so originally will did not
recognize the star of the movie so what
happened so we're all set and you know
there's two hundred dancers standing
around and I'm talking to the director
you know really guys fault
yes I think we do just comes up and he
said he like standing in our
conversation and I'm like that's a bold
ass little dancer go stand and you know
the middle is directly in the genies
conversation and it just stood there and
then walked away and then I guess like I
came back because I was like I didn't
really tell him who I was so I came back
and introduced myself I realized ya know
cuz I was feeling like a security
situation you know like hey I don't want
that dude like imagine we're talking he
just did this so we done it right it was
just like that I was like oh that's
weird that's weird
what are you wearing I'll leave you
alone no no taking you out I mean I like
we both going a lot we both gonna learn
I really think we are launching the
Aladdin collection tonight I want to ask
you also about this stamp so they get
this stamp for you yes so it's called an
ox a as it's an ox a it's a Korean stamp
and on it is my name in Korean and
apparently the the Royals in Korea
didn't write their names they had a
royal stamp so at the interviewer gave
me one and I looked at it I was like
this that's hot it just looked like Fox
it looked like Jamie fire looks like
Jamie Foxx damn I feel like Jamie Foxx
is Stan you know so I mean it happens in
Korea it does happen but you look like
Jamie Foxx now last thing you had a lot
of swag about the topknot and you talked
about and we went and talked to Jada and
she said oh yeah I was definitely
feeling about myself I'm telling you man
Rock the top not you just don't know
what the world will move out your way
man I'm telling you put it on Dawg you
like use you slipping so okay so next
carpet and I'm gonna come when we're
together I'm gonna come on the top 9 I
got the person that will hook it up for
you I know um yeah you know cuz you're
not living your best life you're not
living your best I'm just saying and as
I'm not judging I'm just saying there's
a whole lot more you could be
experiencing you look like a prince on
the outside but I didn't change anything
on the inside
[Music]